loves america
a
different kind of america not the same
america that uh
maybe you love not the same america that
i love i don't think he loves what type
of america do you think biden likes i
think uh the there is
look she said something very important
at the beginning she said the reason why
it's easy for me to represent um um
scientists is because i agree on
everything he talks about that's not
easy to do by the way right i mean you
have to know you represent somebody like
i don't know if i agree with what you
said right let me tell you what
president trump was really trying to say
yeah exactly so it's challenging to be a
press secretary for somebody like trump
because trump is very what
unpredictable right where desantis is
very
predictable right do i sit there and
think he loves uh
america
i don't i don't know if he loves america
i think he's so you don't think biden
loves america i don't think biden loves
the freedom of speech i don't think
biden loves you having the choice to do
what you want to do
in every possible way i think biden
loves democrats i don't think biden
loves america this is why i asked a
question from her on
who does desantis love more florida or
america that's a pointed question
because if you love america america kind
of needs a president like him where he's
calm collected family guy go run do your
thing and go back to your family spend
time with your wife and kids i think
he's more his political party over
america which is
left and right i think desantis is more
for
those who believe in what america was
founded on freedom leave me alone a
little bit of a
free enterprise free market capitalism i
think you can make a decision for
yourself where i think he thinks the
government can make better decisions for
you than you can make for yourself
that's what i mean that his america is a
different america than mine you're
saying you're saying he believes in
america but with a little bit more uh
government overreach like like it's
saying does that does that parent love
his kids i think he loves his kids
but his method of
raising his kids is too much control i
don't believe he's so much of a micro
manager
i i don't think he has any idea what's
going on today i just think he thinks he
knows what's best for you over you know
what's best christina do you have strong
feelings on this do you think biden
loves america do you think he's in his
right mind doing the best job he can do
for america what are your thoughts
i mean to be honest he's been in
politics for 50 years right i mean so
he's been in washington dc
in that bubble and it really is a bubble
you know when you're an elected official
there in congress in the senate and the
vice president and he's just been in
this world that most americans do not
live in it's a very different world and
i think he he believes he's doing the
right things i think he believes that he
he loves america but he doesn't love
the individual liberties aspect that our
country was founded on i don't think i i
tend to agree that um
that he
believes big government is the solution
to everything and perhaps that's because
he's been in government for his whole
career i mean like look when you've been
in washington dc and that's been your
entire life and he hasn't owned a
business you know like he hasn't um
dealt with the same types of things that
american families deal with every day he
just has a different kind of life um
then that's maybe why his perspective is
is so different um from somebody who
let's say who was a business owner
before like trump or somebody who comes
from a more middle class or
working-class background like desantis
and just knows what like lives in a
different state and knows what people in
our state are dealing with so yeah i
don't know why so do you think he loves
america
yeah i do think he loves america do you
think trump loves america i do think
trump loves america do you think i think
i think do you think bernie sanders
loves america
i think uh
i do think bernie sanders loves america
less than those two you think aoc loves
america i do i just think she's got a
different interpretation so we're saying
the same thing so that's exactly what
we're saying yeah you can you can love
the country but have a different vision
no no no then no no that's not how this
thing works but
you're you're systemically wanting this
great country to change you systemically
don't
you don't like what the foundation of
what this country was like don't you
think fdr loved america
do i because he got a lot of heat after
the new deal about social security and
medicare and medicaid and big government
but by now everyone loves that yeah no
no i everybody loves what i mean those
systems i i you doubt any seniors or old
people or sick people are trying to
not have social security wait a minute
wait a minute okay i'm just putting a
difference now you're you're going into
a different direction give the whole
story in the context because first of
all when he came out with social
security do you know how many people use
social security the first year when he
came out with social security well there
weren't that many old people at that
point that's the point so it wasn't a
big deal so there's no doubt social
security is i'm not saying no
fdr isn't as bad as the right painting
out to be and isn't as great as the left
paints them out to be so to me fdr a lot
of times oh my gosh they say bad things
about fda you're looking like he raised
minimum wage one time i think obama
raised minimum wage four times he raised
and obama only raised it one time do you
know who raised minimum wage the most
times like he raised it to 25 cents he
just had 25 cents what the minimum wage
ought to be and he you know kind of went
after four because ford was essentially
having their average employee working 70
hours a week i think that's also a
little bit of use by not choice that's
w-2 not 10.99 it's not sales but i will
tell you this in regards to
uh biden when when you're in a bubble
for too long
i run sales organizations you know what
i do so
i'll talk to my sales leaders and a
sales leader will ask me and say hey pat
man how do you deal with these guys that
are just making 15 bucks an hour man you
trying to get these guys to realize you
got to work hard you got to have your
dreams become a reality
man why do people have such bad habits i
just have a hard time talking to these
people sometimes
it's a very big red flag
very very big red flag why
the moment you lose the ability to
understand
what you were like when you sucked at
one point
you lose the vote
the moment you forget about the pains of
what it was to be broke you lose the
vote the moment you forget about what it
is to be a small business owner if
you've never experienced it dude i
understand the pain of a small business
owner i understand the pain of a kid
that's coming up that wants to do
something with their lives and they got
bad habits i understand what it is to be
in a bubble of nightclubs and you're
stuck in it and you just can't wait to
leave it because but at the same time
like dude but i miss that nightlife it's
a bubble we everybody if you get too
caught up in the bubble that you're in
you're blindsided by reality we all will
go through it i just think he's in a
state where he's so blindsided i don't
know how many core
to the core beliefs he has that he's
presenting i think it's a lot of me too
core beliefs i think aoc has core
beliefs i think sanders has core beliefs
i think trump has core beliefs i think
obama has core beliefs i think those
guys the santa's core beliefs trump core
beliefs i i don't see a desantis as core
beliefs oh you mean biden i i don't i'm
sorry my apologies i don't see biden as
corporal she's about to jump out of
herself i don't see i don't see biden's
core beliefs i think he's been in it for
so long that he's just kind of like yeah
uh i'm a democrat we should do this
oh you guys are changing yeah we should
do i think it's too much about
you know the whole flip-flopping thing
no you got to have a backbone you got to
stand up and you got to get some people
to get upset about your saying hey
here's what i believe this is what we
need to do this is what it was founded
on so yeah i think he loves a different
america so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]